- This videos is brought
to you by Surfshark VPN.
(upbeat music playing)
What's up everyone?
Michael here,
and today I'm gonna do
a philosophical reaction
to the show that dared to ask,
what if Tupac has been alive
in Amsterdam the entire time?
- Pretty sure that's Tupac.
- What?
- I'm talking about
season three of Atlanta.
Now, in the first two seasons,
they used things like
surrealism, absurdism,
a little bit of existentialism,
to explore possibility contained
in seemingly impossible situations i.e.,
that an aging weed dealer could become
an international rap superstar,
that a college dropout
living in a storage space,
could be the manager for that superstar,
or that you can barter your
way to wealth in any situation.
- Actually, let me get this sword, man.
- But, in season three,
they seem to be exploring
the opposite perspective.
Which is, that sometimes,
situations that seem like they're brimming
with pure possibility,
actually are riddled with impossibility
and really finite limits.
And, in particular,
that these impossibilities can
stem from things like racism,
colonialism and it's deep history.
And, these things are so ingrained
into the fabric of reality and society,
as to make them unavoidable.
I wanna check out just a couple
of episodes from this season
to see how some philosophy
might help us make sense
of what's going on,
and might help us understand
the larger implications
of what went down this season.
So, welcome to Philosopher
Reacts to Atlanta season three.
And, spoilers ahead for the show Atlanta,
which we're watching.
Obviously.
But, before we dive in,
I wanna talk about this
videos sponsor Surfshark VPN.
Surfshark VPN secure protocols
and uncrackable encryption,
keep your personal information
safe as you navigate the web.
Now, one of my favorite things
about using a secure VPN like Surfshark,
is that it helps me avoid price gouging.
It's actually pretty simple,
because Surfshark hides my location
websites can't inflate their
prices based on that location.
And, that can add up
to significant savings.
Especially when shopping for
things like plane tickets,
which are very expensive right now.
Another of Surfshark's perks
is secure file sharing.
Because all of your internet
traffic is encrypted,
your downloads remain safe and secure.
So, go ahead.
Download every image that comes up
when you search for
Kierkegaard and Nietzsche,
but in bikinis sipping cocktails.
And, no one will ever know.
Not that I've ever done
that or made those images.
One subscription covers all
of your favorite devices
from your laptop, Xbox, and Android,
all the way to your Amazon
Fire Stick and beyond,
including options for apps
like Chrome and Firefox.
So, get started today by clicking the link
in the description and using
the promo code wisecrack.
When you do, you can get
Surfshark VPN for 83% off,
plus three extra months for free.
Go to Surfshark.deals/wisecrack
or hit the link in the description.
Protect yourself online and
download Surfshark VPN today.
And now, back to the show.
Okay, so it was hard to pick
from all the episodes this season.
I wanna start with episode four.
It's called, "The Big Payback."
Which shows us what happens when Doug,
from The Hangover movies,
starts a new life in Atlanta,
far from his sociopathic friends.
Note that he's perusing the snacks.
Uh-oh. He's gonna grab the cookies.
He's gonna grab some cookies.
Oh boy.
- Your order.
- Wow. Now, the ball's rolling.
Ah, he's gonna give it back?
Oh, he's happy with himself.
He's eating his crime cookies.
He's so happy about it.
Okay. This is important.
- [Radio Guest] You have a
black man suing Josh Beckford,
an early investor in Tesla,
due to the fact that his
ancestors were enslaved
by relatives of Mr. Beckford's.
That human capital and
profit can be directly linked
to the financials of the company.
So, I do think there's merit.
I mean he could win the lawsuit.
- [Radio Host] Not could win. Did win.
Mr. Mbaye did win the lawsuit,
a scenario that seemed.
- The look on his face right there.
That subtle head shake.
I like what's going on here,
and I think that the cookie
scene is interesting, right.
'Cause we see this character get away
with stealing something
without consequences,
and being happy that he stole
it without consequences.
We then cut to a scene
where he's in the car
with his daughter,
and we hear about a trial taking place,
where a black person sues
an early investor in Tesla,
'cause his ancestors were
enslaved by his relatives.
But, this brings up this question
of how much our identities
and our own sense of responsibility,
is tied to our past and our history.
So, if we think about this in a classic
existentialist framework,
there's this idea that we're
born completely free, right?
Unshaped by external or historical forces,
and we, and we alone,
are responsible for our choices.
But, not for those of our
parents, our grandparents,
our great-great-grandparents, and so on.
This is why Sartre very early on says,
"Existence precedes essence."
Meaning that what we do shapes who we are,
and there's not this thing of
who we are is pre-programmed,
that's determining who we are.
Sartre also says that,
"Man is condemned to be free."
But here, the show seems to be starting
to pose this question of,
what responsibility do we bare
for choices made by past generations?
Particularly, if we benefit
in seemingly unfair ways
from those choices.
This brings up this question
of freedom versus facticity.
So, when we think about
freedom philosophically,
for me at least,
I think about the ability
to self-determine.
So, if I have freedom I
have the ability to reflect,
decide on a course of action,
and self-determine that action.
But, there's this other
thing called facticity,
and facticity describes
elements of my existence
that I'm sort of born into.
Martin Heidegger used the term thrownness
to talk about this.
So, when I'm thrown into existence,
I didn't choose who my parents were.
I didn't choose where I was born.
We don't choose our hair color,
when we're born in history,
our class status.
We're just tossed into existence
by two people who had sex.
Facticity describes all of those things
that we're born into that are
outside of our control, right?
Right here, they're
bringing up this question.
Are we responsible for
that facticity, right?
Are we purely free,
or is it the case that people
could be held responsible
for the actions of their ancestors,
and how that affected their lives?
And, obviously,
here they're connecting that
to the idea of reparations,
which is the idea that America
owes financial reparations
to the ancestors of enslaved people.
Who again, people who were enslaved,
were thrown into that situation.
They did not freely will,
or determine to be that.
We kind of have those
twin questions right here.
Who is responsible for what,
and what is the limit of responsibility
when we look at history?
Our main character, of course,
ends up getting sued by someone,
because his ancestors enslaved hers
and she wants some money for it,
and he's not handling it well.
So, he reaches out to some
co-workers for their opinion.
- Hey man, how you doin?
- Pretty good.
- His whole demeanor has changed,
now that he's on the other side of things.
(chips crunching)
- I know this is a crazy
time and everything,
and I really don't know what to do.
No thanks.
I'm just a guy, you know,
trying to get by,
and I feel like this
woman is harassing me.
I just don't know what to do.
- Yeah.
That whole notion of I'm
just a guy trying to get by,
really seems like it's him
trying to disconnect himself
from his history and the
way he's benefited from it.
- The only thing you can
do is say you were wrong,
and give her as much money as you can.
She'll probably wanna
meet with you one on one.
Cut you down a bit.
- I just don't know what to do.
- Honestly, my advice,
gotta fight that (beep), man.
- It's like when you're a kid
and one parent says something
you don't wanna hear,
so you go to the other parent
hoping they'll say that.
It's basically what he's doing here.
Okay, so we're sticking with this question
of responsibility, right?
This guy seems to be making the argument
that he bares no personal responsibility
to the woman suing him,
and thus he shouldn't owe
her any money in the present.
Which builds on this
existential assumption
that he's only responsible
for his freely-willed actions,
and that his identity isn't
tied to anything other than
a sort of pure ontological freedom.
Now, the philosopher Lewis Gordon,
coined the term black existentialism.
Gordon takes the existentialist
concept of bad faith.
And, bad faith describes
what happens when we
basically try to treat ourselves
as objects without freedom,
rather than subjects who have freedom.
Sartre uses the famous example
of waiter that's performing
the identity of waiter in a cafe.
That's in his book,
"Being and Nothingness."
But, Gordon takes this
concept of bad faith
and uses it to better understand racism.
Now, Gordon says,
"The Sartrean position
raises the question of racism
as a form of bad faith since
it is a form of evasion
of human reality."
So, this means that in
acting like institutional
historical racism doesn't have
tangible effects in reality,
white people like our guy in the episode,
are performing that type of bad faith.
When he's huddled with his co-workers
it seems like everyone's performing
that same type of bad faith.
They're evading the
reality of their history,
of the country, of their situation.
I wanna jump to later in the episode
where this all gets laid out
there a lot more clearly.
Marshall is now de-camped to a hotel,
because in his eyes his
life is falling apart a bit.
And, he makes a friend at the hotel bar.
- Two days ago I had a good life,
and now I'm being (beep)
by some (beep) that I didn't even do.
- So, that line there,
when he says he's being (beep)
by some (beep) that he didn't even do.
It's still that idea that
he's disconnected from history
in that way, and shouldn't
bare responsibility.
- Maybe it's only right.
- E, we don't deserve this.
- Well, what do they deserve?
We were treating slavery
as if it were a mystery.
- Yeah, he's basically saying
that they're not treating
the history of slavery as a real,
material, historical thing
that actually happened.
- So, now you're what?
You're separated from you're wife?
She's taking your kid.
- God, this is intense.
- Now, she has to be
raised without a father.
She has to build wealth and success
from the ground up, right?
It's similar to the
position we put them in.
We're gonna be okay.
Your daughter's gonna be okay.
A curse was lifted from her.
- That's interesting.
When he says the curse
has been lifted from her,
it's sort of like by taking
responsibility for that history,
his daughter will be untethered from that.
We're getting at that fundamental question
of how we relate our freedom
to historical responsibility.
And, I've talked about Sartre already,
but it's important to note,
that Sartre actually changed his position
from his early existentialism,
to his later position.
He started to doubt the
type of pure existentialism,
which is kinda similar
to Marshall's vibe here,
in which social and
political history aren't tied
to our free existence.
I think during the time where
Sartre changed his mind,
he also got really influenced by Marxism,
and the work of people like Frantz Fanon.
Now, in an interview
that took place in 1969,
Sartre was asked to
describe the relationship
between his early and late work,
and during the interview,
Sartre recalls himself writing that,
"Whatever his circumstances,
and wherever the site,
a man is always free to
be a traitor or not."
And then, Sartre tells the interviewer,
"When I read this, I said to myself:
'It's incredible that I
actually believed that.'"
I think we kinda see both sides of that
at the hotel bar here.
Marshall feels like he shouldn't
have to bare responsibility
for something that he didn't do.
His friend Earnest, is basically saying,
no we can't abstract
ourselves from a real history.
We are tied up in this
whether you like it or not.
When he says,
"Confession isn't absolution,"
which means you can't
just my bad racism away.
He's saying it has real,
historical, and material effects.
And, Earnest's position,
is similar to Sartre's later synthesis
of existentialism with
historical materialism.
Now, historical materialism is the idea
that history is shaped
by material conditions,
material activities, economic reality.
History isn't just shaped
by ideas, but what happens.
In books like, "Search For A Method,"
and, "Critique of Dialectical Reason,"
Sartre gets into this and kind
of has his existential cake,
while eating his historical
materialism, too.
Now, when this guy Earnest,
ties together historical
facticity, and economic reality,
he's arguing against the
type of racist bad faith
that we saw in the work of Lewis Gordon.
He's operating in good faith in a sense,
'cause he's acknowledging
that things like slavery
and colonialism have absolutely shaped
the material and economic
reality of lots of people.
Some for better. Some for much worse.
And, that his subject group
has benefited from this.
Now, there's a quote from
Frantz Fanon that I like here.
Fanon says,
"Genuine disalienation
will have been achieved
only when things,
in the most materialist sense,
have resumed their rightful place."
I think what Fanon's saying there,
is that ending a racist disalienation
isn't just about thinking better ideas,
or agreeing to better as people,
but about materially
transforming conditions.
And Earnest, in this clip,
seems to be saying that
economic justice, reparations,
is part of what it means
to take responsibility.
You know, what he does
after that is a little much.
We're not going to show that.
You can watch it for yourself.
But, I think that episode really opens up
a lot of interesting things.
You might have noted, however,
that the episode doesn't
feature any of the characters
that we think of when we think of Atlanta.
So, I wanna check out another episode
where we're gonna see
all of our friends again.
Okay, so now I wanna check
out the episode called,
"White Fashion."
I wanna look at both Darius
and Paper Boi's journeys in this episode.
So, let's start by watching
Darius's arc in the episode,
where he experiences the struggle
of trying to share his culinary
culture with a white lady,
who at first, seems genuinely
curious and interested.
So, let's get started there.
- Are you Naija?
- Yes, I'm Naija.
- Couldn't tell. Your hair is so igbo.
- So, this seems like a nice moment.
- River state. Ijaw.
- Where Darius is just sharing his culture
with someone else.
He's connecting with
this restaurant owner.
This is great.
- Ugh, I love her.
- Yeah, she's sweet.
- I need to get her business card.
There is a lot of growth potential.
- This is where it gets weird.
Right when she says there's
a lot of growth potential.
It's like that shift
from looking at a culture
in an appreciative way,
and now seeing growth potential.
- I mean, I like fish,
but boneless fish is...
- Is your Shazam working?
- And even that, that she has
to Shazam to know the music.
Okay.
It seems like we're
getting more of that type
of bad faith that Gordon talks about,
in so much as this woman
doesn't really seem
to be considering the
cultural significance
of Darius being originally from Nigeria.
What it means to be at this restaurant
experiencing another culture.
Especially a culture that was
under British colonial power
until the 1960's.
Sartre said, and he said
this about reading Fanon.
He said,
"Have the courage to read it,
primarily because it will
make you feel ashamed,
and shame, as Marx said,
is a revolutionary feeling."
I think in a sense in this scene,
we don't see a lot of shame in this woman,
and that lack of shame seems to allow her
to see everything in this
restaurant as a product,
or a possibility.
When Sartre makes this point
in his preface to Fanon's book,
he seems to be saying that the effects
of western colonialism of slavery,
should make people feel ashamed,
'cause that shame could lead
them to breaking that cycle
of racist bad faith and changing things.
I wanna now jump to see what happens.
It's not good.
We'll just watch it really quickly though.
So, here he goes back to the restaurant.
It's closed down.
- Yo! Darius.
Over here.
- The white lady is there.
She has started a Nigerian food truck.
- So, she relocated?
Where's Mimi?
- I don't know.
We actually never exchanged info, so.
- Ugh.
- What's in it?
- It's a peach barbecue
reduction and chunks.
I call it the Darius,
'cause you're from Georgia.
- She even named a dish after him.
So, like I said before,
there's some irony here,
because the country of Nigeria
was colonized by Britain.
And now, this British woman
has basically colonized
a Nigerian restaurant.
In the same book I just quoted
where Sartre's talking about Fanon,
Fanon himself says,
"When I look for man in European
lifestyles and technology,
I see a constant denial of man,
and avalanche of murders."
I think similar to the bad
faith black existentialism,
Fanon is here pointing out
that when European
lifestyle and technology
denied the humanity of black
people and their culture,
it allows them to instrumentalize them,
and use them as they would
any other product or resource.
And in this case,
this woman doesn't seem to be recognizing
the humanity of a Nigerian woman,
and her restaurant and her culture.
She sees a concept that can be used
to create profit for herself.
And, of course,
Darius seems to be realizing
this all in real time.
This is from Sartre's preface once again.
He says,
"You who are so Liberal, so humane,
who take the love of culture
to the point of affectation,
you pretend to forget
that you have colonies
where massacres are
committed in your name."
I think when Sartre here
talks about loving a culture
to the point of affectation,
he's getting at this idea that
people love cultural products
or aspects of culture,
while conveniently forgetting,
once again kind of in that bad faith way,
that massacres have been
committed in the name
of those peoples countries.
In this case,
we see that with this
woman who's from a culture
that colonized Nigeria,
now micro-colonizing
a Nigerian restaurant.
Now, while all this is
happening in the same episode,
Paper Boi is having a similar
experience on a larger scale.
And, it involves a French fashion company.
Okay, so this is presumably a gift,
to that guys grandkid
from the fashion designer.
- Whoa!
- Okay. It's a jersey that
says Central Park Five.
Many of you know that
the Central Park Five,
were a group of young
black men in New York,
who were falsely accused
of murdering a woman.
They were exonerated, but
they spent time in jail.
It was very, very bad.
And, now we're using that trauma and pain
to make clothes for
presumably very rich people.
- We want to apologize to
the community properly.
- Okay.
- With your help.
- And now, the same fashion company,
wants Paper Boi to be one of the faces
of their apologies for doing a racism.
- You're not worried about, you know,
what the streets think?
- The streets?
(laughs) Man, (beep) the streets.
Man, I've shot (beep).
You tryna tell me that
you wouldn't take any
of these free designer gifts?
- Here we are seeing this tension, right,
where Paper Boi's taking
advantage of the situation
to get some designer clothes,
and Earn is asking the question,
can we do something more here.
- Then I'd start my own program.
Help out black entrepreneurs
and business owners.
Like a "We invest in your hood" campaign.
- Earn here, is encouraging
Paper Boi to take advantage
of the situation and
do something positive,
and use his subject position,
as a internationally famous rapper,
to get this fashion
company to do something
to empower Urban communities,
and to even build his own foundation.
There's a Fanon quote that I
think applies a little bit here
where Fanon says,
"For Europe, for ourselves,
for humanity, comrades,
we must make a new start,
develop a new way of thinking,
and endeavor to create a new man."
Fanon thought it was possible
to create a new world,
and a new humanism.
And by a new humanism,
he means like a new universal
conception of humanity.
He thinks we do this by
first rethinking the type
of western humanism associated with
the western philosophical tradition,
and white European humans.
So, rather than just making the
category human, or humanism,
this white European human thing.
He wants it to apply to everyone.
But, of course,
Earn's ideas here assume a world
where a multi-national fashion company,
would have a genuine interest
in helping use their capital
to directly invest in black communities.
We see how this goes a little bit,
when we get to the press conference,
where Paper Boi has to
apologize for racism.
So, let's cut there really quick.
- Clermont with Le Parisien
- Um, Paper Boi,
after this is racism over?
- Okay, so she just asked Paper Boi.
She said, "Paper Boi,
after this is racism over?"
- Um, (beep) no.
Obviously. (laughs)
I mean look at the porn industry, right?
- I think what he means, is
that with our new initiative,
we believe racism will be done by 2024.
- He said racism will be done by 2024.
After that experience and
seeing the press conference,
Paper Boi wants to sort of
listen to Earn's advice.
He comes up with a pitch.
- I just got this idea about
black people making money.
You know what I'm saying?
And, putting them black
dollars in black hands,
and then we just support
black business, right?
'Cause if you take them dollars,
and put them back in your neighborhood,
your neighborhood will grow.
So, I figure we just call it
the reinvest in your hood campaign, right?
Think about it.
Reinvest in your hood.
- Again, we see Paper Boi truly wanting
to do something positive.
Create some type of change.
Now, here's the ad that the
fashion brand comes up with.
- [Paper Boi] Reinvest in your hood.
Think about it.
'Cause if you take them dollars,
and put them back in your neighborhood,
your neighborhood will grow.
- Oh boy.
- Reinvest in your hood.
- We got cowboys. We got kids and goats.
- We're all from some hood.
- We have old white ladies.
- Okay, so this ad seems to be precisely
what someone like Fanon
was worried about, right?
It takes a sort of white Liberal humanism,
and says that black people count,
but so do rich white ladies,
because they're all from some hood.
Sartre grew more cynical in his later work
in the "Critique of Dialectical Reason."
Sartre argued that while
human freedom is capable
of rising up and trying
to change the world,
and he calls these moments apocalypses.
That these movements
of freedom and equality
run up against institutions.
So, those could be states,
governments, businesses.
And, here it seems like
Paper Boi's attempt
to use his freedom in a certain situation
to do something positive,
was met with the power of the institution
that is a fashion company
and a marketing ecosystem,
in which inclusion only matters
when it's including new consumers,
who could potentially buy their clothes.
Sartre say,
"Demanding yet denying the human condition
makes for an explosive contradiction."
And, it seems like that's
what's happening here.
They're both demanding and
denying the human condition
in this case for black people,
and people effected by their
very messed up ad campaign.
So, the last clip I wanna look at.
You know, we have the
aftermath of Paper Boi
seeing the commercial that
the fashion company made.
- (beep), I know what the
(beep) the Red Cross is.
It's the worst one.
- I mean this is intense
here in this scene,
'cause you see Paper Boi, Alfred,
kind of like losing hope.
- Relax. Relax.
- Stop playing with me, man.
- What I wanna do is
go in there with a bat
and knock they asses.
- You wanna go in there...
- Yeah, I wanna do that.
- And beat their asses?
- Why you ain't mad?
- (laughs) Look, ask yourself this.
Why?
Why would a company make a project
that would teach black people
to stop buying their products,
and reinvesting their own?
- (mouth smacks) Man.
- Why would they fund their own demise?
- He says, "Why would they
fund their own demise?"
- Look, I told you.
I've been doing this social
justice thing a long time.
- Something about that phrasing.
I've been doing this social justice thing.
Here this character is
basically telling Paper Boi
that the type of change
he wants is impossible
in the current system.
Think back to Sartre's notion
of institutions, right?
In this case,
the institution of the fashion
industry and capitalism,
are stopping what Paper Boi wants to do.
In a sense we see the limits
of the optimism we find in Fanon's work.
And, this brings up a
concept call Afropessimism,
which is a philosophy attributed
to the work of Frank Wilderson.
And, unlike Fanon's
call for a new humanism
that would move past
colonization and racism,
Wilderson doesn't think
that racism is fixable.
He says at one point,
"Blackness is coterminous with slaveness."
And, in a New Yorker review,
they actually compare his
position to Fanon's and say,
"That for Wilderson,
Fanon's cup is too full.
Other previously colonized
peoples are indeed human,
but not black people.
One of the bleakest aspects
of Afropessimist thought,
is it's denial that there
is a meaningful analogy
between blacks and other nonwhites."
And this is all very intense sounding,
but for someone like Wilderson,
the issues at play here,
the legacies of things like
slavery, and colonization,
and anti-black racism,
are baked to deeply into society,
and into western
capitalism to just change.
Especially, not via a marketing campaign.
Now, I think then with that in mind,
we could read this conversation
that Paper Boi has,
as this idea that a system
built on capitalism,
and colonization, and slavery,
is never gonna have space
for real black liberation
built into it.
So, the best thing that can happen,
is that some rich
companies funnel some money
into some non-profits,
so some people can do
some good stuff with that.
And in this episode,
it seems like we kind of go from
a more Fanon inspired optimism, humanism,
to a more Afropessimistic position,
Allah the word of Wilderson.
Now, in this episode,
both Paper Boi and Darius run up against
the limits of freedom,
and their own existential control.
Darius sees how an earnest,
and seemingly kind attempt,
to share a bit of his culture
with a new friend can backfire,
when that person just views
that culture as a product
to be repackaged in a food truck.
And then, Paper Boi runs
up against the institutions
of capitalism and consumerism,
and realizes that no
amount of good intentions
can make those systems less corrupt.
Okay, so it seems that in this season,
by introducing a level harsh impossibility
into the lives of its characters,
the show is trying to explore a sense
of finitude in the world.
The idea that there's
somethings that we can't change
and maybe that we'll
never be able to change.
Whether it be matters of racial identity,
the histories of
colonialism and capitalism,
or even our individual identities.
And in doing this,
the show is following a bit
of a post-existentialist
philosophical agenda, right?
With Sartre,
we're seeing how a seemingly
limitless existential freedom
can run up against the
limits of institutions.
With Fanon, we're
exploring the alienation,
and unconscious violence
that colonialism and racism
have cooked into society,
and asking whether or not
a new humanism is possible.
With Wilderson, and the Afropessimist,
the show seems to be
asking if these problems
can ever be solved,
and considering that
maybe this type of racism
is a permanent feature of western culture.
And, of course,
it's kinda fitting that
this all takes place against
the backdrop of Europe.
A place that in one
sense seems more forward
and progressive than America,
but is also directly haunted
by the colonial violence
of its past.
Do let us know what you
think in the comments.
And as always, if you enjoy this video,
like, subscribe, ring that bell.
Thank you so much to our patrons,
and if you haven't
checked it out in a while,
give our Patreon page a glance,
'cause we've got some great
new stuff going on there.
And, remember to check out
our new stream Wisecrack Live.
It happens right here every
Thursday at 11 a.m. Pacific.
And as always, thank you
so much for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music playing)